[Music]
you
protons and neutrons the electron clouds
scattered around
atoms packed and lattice is stacked
among billions and trillions of their
kind and around trillions more they wind
and we see that they are formed into
this thing
they die on those before me colleague
gets our string
[Music]
we think we see this world but we see a
fraction of a fraction and even what we
can see is just photonic reactions and
we think that it's gorgeous and that
nothing could compare but how could we
ever know when so much more out there
[Music]
protons and neutrons the electron clouds
scattered around
carbon in oxygen and nitrogen and
hydrogen forming two of the simplest
proteins and stacked together into beta
pleated sheets and out from my finger
grows this thing that I smack up and
down on this guitar string
we think we see this world but we see a
fraction of a fraction and even what we
can see is just photonic reactions and
we think that it's gorgeous and that no
thing could compare but how could we
ever know when there's so much more out
there
[Music]